good evening everybody welcome to Perry
West hello my name's Justin courage on
the chair in front of me here are the
other counselors who are part of the
committee and to my left and right
officers of the council who will help us
in making our decisions this evening if
I can ask them to introduce themselves
Olivia Quinn Witte services Ross
chambers legal services my name is David
Jeffrey I'm the Western team leader in
my role as an impartial adviser to the
committee I can clarify any planning
issues that arise doing so I am bound by
the code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal Town Planning Institute planning
committee members are not bound by the
case officers recommendation or by oral
advice
Charlotte Dix Senior Planner Sarah
McPherson planning officer lovely thank
you so apologies of absence Jerry got
apologies from cancer at concern he
can't see fielding subbing for and
councillor Vaudrey lovely thank you any
disclosures of interest ok thank you
first item chair on the ward member and
I'm here with open minds I've not made
any representations so I'll stay on the
committee
thank you the planning applications item
number three the old British shop
the green clevedon and Charlotte Dix if
you can run us through that piece Thank
You chairman decisis indicated on the
map by the black circle the application
site is located on the northern edge of
the village of coverton within the West
Midlands Greenbelt an art and special
landscape area this side shows the
application site edged in red located
towards the center of the slide the site
has a great two listed building
curtilage is two buildings and is also
within the conservation area which is
indicated by the pink line the other
visible red buildings are nearby listed
buildings whilst the dotted green lines
tonight public rights away there are
dwellings abutting the site to the south
north and west this is an application
for full Planning Commission are listed
building consent for the alteration of
the listed building to reduce the size
of the retail units and first row
extensions create a one-bedroom unit at
first floor this slide shows the
proposed block plan the pink block
donates denotes the retail units at
ground floor with the new residential
unit at first floor whilst the green
block shows the existing dwelling which
is to be altered the partial outlines of
the garage to the south and covered in
court to the north are also visible the
proposed garden area stretches to the
east with the parking area for the
planning units to the south of the
listed building this slide shows the
proposed ground floor on the left-hand
side and the proposed first floor on the
right-hand side again the pink shaded
area shows the alterations to the shop
whilst the green is the existing
dwelling which is to be altered the
yellow lines which are visible at first
floor indicate the proposed first floor
front and side extension which would
create the additional residential unit
this side shows the proposed elevations
the yellow shaded areas indicate the
proposed extension to the front of the
listed building the elevation shown on
the bottom right-hand side of the screen
is the elevation which would be visible
from the road to the front showing how
the addition would project to the front
of the listed building whilst the
elevation seen on the bottom-left of the
screen is a proposed rear elevation this
photo is taken from the north of the
application site with the application
sites on the left-hand side in the
center the listed building with flatteri
front extension is visible centrally
with traveling courts on the left-hand
side this photo is taken from the front
of the site showing the listed building
the outbuilding to the right-hand side
and the twentieth-century flat roof
butcher's shop extension to the front
this side shows the same photo on the
left-hand side
with the proposed elevation on the
right-hand side this illustrates the
proposed front extension and gable
remodeling to the listed building this
photo was taken from the rear garden of
the dwelling facing west towards the
rear elevation the Lister building was
is on the right hand side with the
curtilage listed out building on the
left-hand side
the extension would be located in the
gap between these buildings this photo
again shows the same photo on the
left-hand side with the proposed
elevation drawing on the right-hand side
showing the infilling of this gap this
photo was taken from the rear garden of
the site facing south towards the rear
elevation of number-two clover down
helping to show the relationship between
these two properties just to clarify
there are updates within the update
sheet officer recommendation is to
refuse full planning permission and
listed building consent for the reasons
stated on pages 15 and 16 of the agenda
thank you chairman thank you very much
and we will first of all here
from the parish council I think
councillor Simon and Lawton who has
three minutes give you two and two and a
half minute warning Thank You chairman
good evening councillors I'm here on
behalf of clavinet parish council we're
here supporting this scheme which
actually we don't like that much and we
know actually the applicants aren't very
keen they really don't want to build it
but it's out of frustration that we
bring this application to committee and
hope that you might find a way to to
allow this application the Parish
Council are concerned that if this
application is refused again in
frustration the applicants will be
forced to develop a scheme approved in
July 2014 now counts as this scheme is a
horrendous extension of an unready
unwanted and letter workshop traveling
over 20 25 years because lost at all in
its shops and that prompted the village
to set up its own now thriving community
shop run by volunteers it doesn't make
any money it breaks even we're
absolutely convinced that if a new shop
came into the village and took some
business away from our community shop
the community shop would close there's
no viability for a shop in Clevedon that
would close the village would end up as
it did before ultimately with no shop
now the PC era where and you can see
from the history on page 4 that for four
years since acquiring the property at
auction the applicants have applied and
withdrawn and been refused and despite
best efforts to get a scheme acceptable
to planning officers have just met with
a brick wall this latest not very good
scheme is again recommended for refusal
on meeting the applicants several times
than heard their frustrations in the
officers appear to agree a proposal then
another officer disagrees they have
spent thousands on abortive pounds in it
six fees but to no avail look the final
straw was that they're now being told
that the shop must be marketed for six
months the Parish Council actually
acquired the shop under the well they
didn't acquire it they they stopped the
shop being sold and to see whether we
could let it we tried for a year there
was no interest there's no way this shop
will let and I'm a professional Janssen
surveyor dealing in retail what we want
is to get some sort of agreement at
committee so a project can move forward
the actual important listed building
which is the one to the rear that you
saw in the green that is falling to bits
there's IV running food rebuilding it's
it's a shocking shame looking like this
is very second another chart severe
David Middleton believes it's probably
unrepairable now it's been left so long
the actual report listed buildings in
ruins the existing shop is ugly and of
no architectural merit we don't need or
want a retail unit we hope that with
consent granted the applicants can start
a proper negotiation with planning
officers to retain and put in good order
the listed building replace the shop
with two small semi-detached houses
which are required and would have the
full support of the parish council and
the village Thank You chair
thank you can't - any questions can Sir
Giles I think I'm just wonder if you can
help me because I think you were talking
about how there's a requirement or
allegedly a requirement for this to be
remarketed and the issues about retail
but it's not one of the reasons that's
given here for refusal it said the
conclusion in the report is based on the
assessment of the information and modest
reduction in retail space wouldn't have
a significant impact on the retail
function of the shop so it's not given
as one of the reasons for refusal so I'm
just wondering why you're saying those
comments irrelevant because councillor
charles in in the in the the the the
several parts bits of correspondence as
i've seen i've actually seen and read
that the one of the planning officers I
went Nemer actually said I now require
this shop to be marketed I mean I've
seen it in black and white it's not in
here but it's just the frustration and
this is why
the applicants are putting in something
they're just anything this is rough
decent but it's not what the village
want and we the frustration is what the
village want here is for the lovely old
building that you can just about see
hidden by this ugly shop to be
completely exposed so you can see it but
this is a Conservation Area this
building to the left when the boarded up
shop and the hip roof building there is
completely out of character it's it's
it's of no interest it's argued that
there is some heritage interest but it
is better to retain the big green house
one nice big sustainable house which is
listed and quite rightly - and to build
two small cottages on the land there you
haven't seen the photographs of the site
but if you panned over to the left I'm
sorry on the right on this photograph
there is an area of land that was an old
garage that has been demolished and
right next to that is a little carpark
and next to that is a row of two
bedroomed terraced houses that were
built in 1960 and looked fine that's all
we want you to just see them there in
the far right hand corner a little bit
of infill development not excessive - -
bedroomed semi-attached bungalows both
series hatch houses would be perfect and
exactly what the village life is we are
straying from what's in front of us
Thank You mr. Perry Thank You chair good
evening Council Orton I just wonder
whether you can explain you mentioned
that I would just like to know why the
permission that was given in 2014 wasn't
followed through then as I understand it
was granted before the the building was
was put to walking by John l and Sons
which is four years ago so it was it was
a planning application that was granted
to the previous owners presume who
helped them sell the site but it truly
is woefully it doubles the size of a
shop that we don't actually want it's
ghastly
click Casa bombs yes in a breeze we have
to advertise shops for six months before
when they're closed so am i right if we
were to approve this application we
would still have to advertise the shop
for six months as I understand it yes
there might be some clarification from
the office on that but as I understand
it when this is built with this unwanted
shop it has to be advertised it won't be
let I mean ultimately it will revert to
residential which you can under national
planning policy if you can prove there's
no requirement for it then it will
become part of a house and it will
become rather than ugly house we just
rather rather see a couple of pretty
houses the fitting level early okay
Clara fielding we we saw the pink and
the green
it showed a first floor flat the pink is
shown as a shot there is no indication
from that that there are two flats there
unless you're assuming that the the pink
will then become the second show you do
not see on technical but I can't answer
it the shot part is on the on the ground
floor there and above it there is an
extended roof which is going to house a
one-bedroom flat I mean ultimately when
the shot doesn't less as a retail unit
that shot will be converted to what we
come a rather ugly house okay
Castle Richards no okay thank you very
much we shall now hear from the
applicants agent Steve Olsen and I write
this this week sir think
okay so again three minutes and I'll
tell you about two and a half last month
yeah
good evening my name is Steve Olsen I'm
a chartered architect at Brock Charles
and we are agent for the applicants the
listed dwelling and shop remained vacant
for over five years now on Weiss the
applicant tries to get into proof of
something more suitable for the locality
following approval was in 2014 depart
demolished the large existing butcher
shop to remove the flat roof I saw for
an enlarged retail premises it's become
apparent that no one wants such a large
business premises in collaborative it
has been previously advertised with no
interest whatsoever the applicant has
more recently applied to remove the shop
and for a home and until tonight the
parish have not supported the
application so each planner decision has
been delegated forcing loop a withdrawal
this application proposes to provide a
small home reduce the retain shop and
salvage the listed dwelling the addition
of the proposed small home makes the
site more economically viable and the
smaller retail premises were more
attractive for business use along with
the proposal excuse me along with the
proposed improvements to the like Ring
Road elevation the new scheme will more
likely attract small business owners to
the village as the streets see more
visually appealing it is proposed to
remove the flat roof or a sympathetic
pitch roof addition in matching
materials to allow enough height for a
one-bedroom home above the shop there is
no overlooking the sewage report
concluded that there will not be a
detrimental view to the listed building
this small first floor extension
continues to Pleasant array of pitched
roof elements and removes the flat roof
or even the conservation officer agrees
is damaging the aesthetics of the listed
dwelling
we believe that proposal for you tonight
will significantly improve the immunity
of the village and surrounding area and
will not dominate the current setting of
the listed dwelling given though such a
low impact additionally when enhance the
current street scene the applicant has
tried on numerous occasions to move this
project forward and whilst they wait
patiently for an approval the listed
dwellings existing fabric continues to
decline
the roof and broken windows continued
allow in rainwater causing damage to the
water and floor the building is
deteriorating due to the stamps of the
conservation officer I was of the
opinion that the small roof extensions
damaged the setting of the Harwich tacet
but weighed against the existing
arrangements this low impact proposal is
surely significally a significant
departure tonight's for this application
the this local decision-making is that
is trying to provide a small home to the
village improve the retail premises and
bring in abandoned listed building back
to life which is appropriate development
within the conservation air and green
belt we trust you agree and will approve
education tonight so that the applicants
can move forward into sense of a
salvaged delisted dwelling provide a new
home in the village and to provide a
visually improved smaller retail
premises that will attract both business
employment to the village this abandoned
quietly decaying central part of
Clevedon deserves improvement and this
proposal offers just that thank you for
your time I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much
councillor Richards covering both the
full and Leslie building consent are
four reasons for refusal three of them
are quite expected staying in sufficient
details of in submitted or insufficient
supporting information has been
submitted can you give us an idea of the
dialogue that you've had with officers
over that information that's been
required and if you feel you've
submitted it what it is or if you
haven't why as a mr. mrs. come we yeah
if can we if you can zoom in on the
listed dwelling the green bits and the
floor plans Charlotte is that possible I
mean so if you go back to the plans I
mean basically you can see a dark shaded
area in the center of the ground floor
top green top left green there's a dark
shaded shaded area that - to improve the
floor the existing floor Heights very
low the actual changes the list of
dwelling are quite minimal there's a
floor change into the kitchen area we
block up it existing stairs and we
basically either block up or our door
openings internally we thought that
could be agreed by condition for further
detail what were the other three there's
basically three three or four reasons
refusal to say insufficient details of
intermittent or insufficient supporting
information I don't know what they are
what's been asked I am gonna send
questions to the officers but I wait
your yeah we in it before I go ahead and
do okay no we believe that there's
sufficient information on the proposals
for the officers to understand what we
were trying to achieve we were thinking
that if they wanted further information
that that could be agreed by condition I
think it counts are fielding on the
ground floor plan of the shop area pink
which is on the end of the green area on
the first floor it is shown as being
part of the listed building is it does
the current listed building overhang the
shop or is that pink really part of the
shop I don't quite understand the plan
where where is the boundary of the old
listed building so the boundary is so
the the pink which is furthest right
down a bit down a bit down a bit
that's it yeah that piece that is part
of the listed dwelling we are going
through that wall to create some
additional space for the shop I think an
office from memory so so it's not
actually it's slightly misleading it's
not part of the the old shop well I
think the dwelling is listed and there's
Curtis listed by association
with the other premises I think if you
want to clarify that further we can do
it through officers any other questions
nope thank you very much and okay so
we're going to go to questions to the
officers councillor Richards I think the
officers probably know where I'm going
this so obviously the insufficient
details and insufficient information
what is it that you're seeking and based
on the response from the applicants
agent are we able or likely to be able
to condition that information if we
remind it's grunt so the information
that we would require is a more detailed
assessment of the impact on the
significance so it's in relation to the
alterations to the list of buildings
such as the lowering of the floor level
and looking at the historic fabric that
is in evidence in the building at the
moment and what could possibly be lost
it would be difficult to condition that
in terms of because that would be part
of the assessment as to whether it's
acceptable to lose that a fabric or not
so we would need that information
upfront to be able to make that
assessment to then look at the impact on
significance so we it would not be
possible to say subject to approval by
the planning authority and its
conservation assessment no we would need
that information to be able to assess
whether there is going to be a
significant so so for the I think
obviously the Parish Council have made
the point that they want to see this
thing done and dealt with and certainly
for as long as I've been the ward member
for the area that has been a direct
building and certainly looking at the
planning history goes back as far as
2013 which wasn't before us I was
elected it's been there a long time in a
horrible State and it's only gonna get
worse how quickly do you think that
information could come to you how easy
is it to get that information to you so
that they can either resubmit or
or even delay until we've got that info
I think there's really two elements to
this there is inadequate information
overall in respect of what impacts this
proposal will have on the listed
building but also what we have before us
what we have assessed what the
conservation officers provided advice on
is harm at a level which merits a
refusal in officers view there aren't
public benefits to overcome those harms
so even if they were to provide for
example further information in
respective archaeology where they're
lowering the floor level within the
building still wouldn't overcome our
concerns with for example the linking of
those two buildings which doesn't appear
to be merited in these harmful ters
special characteristics of those listed
buildings that seems clear so they can
we can get information on the floor but
it won't overcome the new roof good
sorry
anything else councillor I'm fine so I'm
gonna go to counterbalance first all
shops in my village you always that go
through six months advertising they had
a small shop which nobody wanted
secondhand ladies dress shop been there
eight years they want to expand there is
that the case that this has got to be
advertised if we were to approve we
would normally require marketing
information if the proposal involves the
loss over retail units however this only
involves a minor reduction in the size
of the retail unit so a marketing
assessment wasn't required and wouldn't
be required in the future if if the
proposal is to keep the shop
cancer jars it's obviously been alleged
and we will not know the degree to which
it's not cure it or not but it's been
alleged and we can see for the planning
history there's been a lot of back and
forth on this and I I just wonder
whether the the linear process with
which we deal with this an application
like this and I think it happens on lots
of listed building applications is a bit
difficult in the sense that we and there
is a question at the end of this you
know it's submit
it's either acceptable isn't refused it
seems to me as though it's some of my
maybe what needs to happen is we there's
a more of a collaborative approach which
is what are all the options
let's compare all the options and then
let's look at what we think is the best
and maybe that is is there any ways that
if either this were to be deferred or
refused there's the opportunity for
maybe parish council applicant
conservation officer indeed even maybe
ward member to be involved in some sort
of collaboration to determine what might
be acceptable and then an application be
can be submitted rather than it just
being so maybe a pre-application
collaboration rather than it just being
a refusal I guess in a refusal if you
see what I mean yeah absolutely I think
that the officers would support a
process of pre-application discussions
on any resubmission of this application
it clearly has been an extensive
planning history on on this site and it
is unfortunate they the applicant hasn't
yet found a satisfactory proposal okay
so Perry
Thank You chair I was just interested to
know what sort of discussions perhaps
have been taken to try and see if how
the overlooking concerns have been
addressed obviously because it's 6.5
meters rather than the the 10 meters
which goes against the extension design
guide etc was wasn't was there any way
of looking at obscuring windows or just
seeking further advice to try and
overcome that particular objection so
the proposed plans do indicate that
their kitchen window which is that the
window of concern would be obscurely
glazed however as a house will room
window that's not a solution that we
would be looking to support because of
the overall issues with the with the
proposal as a whole in terms of the
impact on the concert so inputs on the
listed building we have an instance a
dialog in terms of amending the plans as
we do see that there's a significant
harm caused to the listed building
without sufficient public benefits to
outweigh it ok catch the bonds as you
well know mr. German you can ask people
that have spoken before if we really
must become well can what do you suggest
the technical thing is in my eyes it
looks to be preparing and chat together
and get it right but that's no good for
the agent that yep I don't think so
but if we can get a canister filled in
there and we can go further into this
later the parish counselor indicated
that there was a lot of damage due to
broken windows
probably due to Ruth's leakage etc doing
know to what extent the the water in e
getting into the building has caused
rata and other matters that may not on
void any misty building problems that
would come up I think the short answer
to that is no but in the conservation
officers view the benefits of this
proposal in terms of bringing the
building into a sustainable ongoing use
do not outweigh the harm in heritage
terms to this building house the
conservation office have been and
inspected internally yes the
conservation officer has done an
external and internal inspection okay
can we get a debate know once anything
can stop oh I thought you were
stretching this is this is a difficult
application because obviously we've got
expert advice conservation officers
identify and we've got three clear
reasons for a refusal however having
said that the parish council are happy
to support it but don't like what is put
before them and in my view there is an
opportunity here perhaps that it should
be deferred so that officers and parish
council an applicant can get together I
can't support this application so I will
I will just reserve reserve my right for
final point but I'm either looking to go
with the officers recommendation or to
have a deferral to give it one last
chance to see if there is a solution
because it is and I saw in Clevedon
that's not to say we should be doing the
wrong thing in order to overcome that
particular issue I shall wait with
interest to see what my other colleagues
have to say okay cash the widgets thank
you - I imagine we're both we're all
going to say much the same thing if I'm
honest it's self-evident from that
picture alone that this is an eyesore
looking through the planning history
going back to 2013 effort has been made
continually to try and improve this but
clearly there's been stumbling blocks
along the way I think it's important
that it is improved and is dealt with
and as quickly as possible really the
the four reasons and this does encompass
the obviously as well of those four
three of them's also three of those say
insufficient information or insufficient
detail so we as a committee cannot make
a decision with insufficient detail so
from my mind and you're going to
interrupt many say councillor issues
reason for a fuse or one part of that is
about insufficient information the
second chunk of the reason isn't about
insufficient information Lysa refused
yet I'm aware but I am in my mind if
that information comes forward
it may well overcome the issue that's my
view you don't have to share that with
me so that's what I was saying in
sufficient detail we cannot make a
decision with insufficient detail
certainly not one to approve because
clearly there is an issue all that clear
there is other I perceived issues over
the conservation of the of the listed
building so it's important that we do
start to look to make a headway with
this and move it forward I want to
propose that we do defer to allow the
applicant to bring forward the
information that is missing but also to
allow for officers including the
conservation team and the parish council
the agent the applicants and if they
want my input as a ward member I'm more
than happy to do that as well to try and
find a way to get this scheme to a point
where it can be brought for an approval
so that's my proposal and I wonder if I
can get a second if worked okay we've
got a lot of pans
start with councillor Barnes agree the
last speaker
that's why I asked the question about
could I ask the applicant about
deferment I think the six months with
the shop would also be included in that
that's legally what we've got to do
which we have in our other villages but
Melissa's I know the shop quite well my
granddad was born just down the road in
1882
not being there lately but as far as I'm
concerned the way forward the way for he
had a grandmother's clock shot in
Clevedon then known that before the
First World War
and as far as I'm concerned that is in
my eyes the way forward
the quickest way forward and then if
it's got to come back to committee but
also but I should be second in the
proposal made by nan Susan our board
member okay thank you so your second
thing that great Chancellor fielding I'm
concerned about the fabric of the
building being allowed and so therefore
I'm happy to agree with councillor
Richardson pappa and Perry on the
grounds that we've got to get something
done as quickly as possible otherwise
there's going to be detrimental damage
to the fabric if it's larger to go on
and I think to defer it whilst this is
sorted out would be very useful okay
Castle Charles I'm not necessarily
necessarily opposed to deferral but the
issue that I have is that for me
personally I don't know whether I speak
for others but I would be concerned if
that sent a message out that minor
tinkering would make this acceptable
because irrespective of the issue about
insufficient or sufficient information
the thrust of the report is quite clear
and it says that the conservation
officers assessment on the information
it already
he or she already has makes this harmful
the higher end of the scale of less than
a substantial harmon we and we don't
often see that and i have to say i can
understand the reasoning because I think
it's quite clearly sets out on page ten
but we know that this flat roof
prominent forward extension it's agreed
that it's harmful that it harms a listed
building and really what our
conservation officer is saying by making
it bigger
although put a roof on it by making it
more prominent it's going to overshadow
the listed building even more so what
we're doing is taking a problem that's
bad and we're making a lot worse by
extending that roof essentially making
frankly the listed buildings listed
building subservient I agree with
comment here which says it feels like a
lost opportunity to see whether we can
have this extension demolished and
something perhaps in keeping in its
place that leads me to say I understand
what's been said and I look through the
planning history and there was a it
looks as though at one point have been
applications which have looked at the
demolition of that and and it may well
be what was suggested to replace it
wasn't acceptable but I would be more
comfortable with something that looks at
making a major improvement because if if
a deferral could be productive and I
agree with about about putting a little
bit of into where we are I think just
simply it would be shame to refuse the
application just go through this whole
process again if it could if it can be
purposive in the sense that there might
be the possibility of actually having a
substantial alteration I'm not
necessarily opposed but I am I am
worried if we just defer it with it
coming back you know looking marginally
the same I'd frankly I'd rather just
refuse it now and get on with the best
application so I probably won't my some
advice okay we shall get that in a
moment
didn't counsel organ Thank You chairman
I agree with cancer Giles I think there
is a fundamental problem with this it's
not just a question of thinking
tinkering around the edges
that a deferral would in I think be
there to to resolve as well as that I'm
confused about this business of the shop
or not to have a shop
and it seems to me that it's going to be
anyway a stepping stone to something
else because if there is not a market
for the shop then surely it's better to
come along with the whole nine yards and
have the evidence that it's not viable
and a scheme that is actually what it is
going to be that will sort everyone so I
don't support councillor Richards
proposal and I would seek a refusal
thank you okay I've just put my my bid
in here I'm I'm in agreement with the
last two speakers I think I think it's
been clearly shown by the report that
our conservation officers is not happy
with with the roof and so so amending
and information ain't going to change
the roof but so I wouldn't be going for
a deferral I would be absolutely
suggesting that we somehow work better
together to get a solution for this
village which obviously needs it in the
conservation area can we have a comment
yes happily to support your views chair
the comments of the conservation officer
the views of planning offices are that
this work on the roof the new first
floor essentially is not acceptable it's
not a minor tinkering that is required
it would be substantially a different
planning application in that sense it's
not something that we would really seek
to defer a decision on it's more
something we would seek to set out our
concerns through a decision notice a
refusal in this case and then when the
applicant resubmits or seeks to engage
in pre-application discussions engage
with that and trying to reach a
satisfactory conclusion okay but we do
have a proposal and a seconder so we
will vote on that the proposal is to
defer
the the application for more information
to come forward
okay so okay so there's two issues here
we've got the listed building consent
and we've got the normal planning
applications as two votes and I'm being
asked for clarification on the kind of
information that proposes seeking from
this so as I've said Tom consistently
throughout this for this evening
three of your reasons for refusal say in
sufficient detail
I don't want detail you're expecting but
clearly it's insufficient so it's
sufficient detail for you to be able to
satisfy yourself that it's not
insufficient anymore does that make
sense I think that's clear actually I'll
go with that we've got insufficient
mentioned at least twice there it
doesn't it doesn't apply to the
potentially substantive reason for
refusal however you that known you know
the substantive reason for refusal is
the damage this will do that will not be
changed through consultation and
information coming forward other
information can come forward on other
aspects if that's what you wish
although the substantive reason for
refusal will remain but I'm sure
officers can can I think that's the
clarity we're looking for our members by
deferring this asking for us in respect
of particularly the first reason for
refusal to seek further statements in
respect of significance and impact on
special interest or are they seeking for
officers to negotiate amendments to the
appearance and design of this
development and if so what changes are
in your view appropriate given the
comments and within the committee report
so in the first instance my view is to
get the
information that is lacking I don't
think it's in our gift as committee to
make changes to this application
it is however in the gift of the
applicant to submit amendments if they
would if they were so inclined to do now
if we get this information and it
overcomes any of the substantive reasons
that have been put then we can move
towards a an approval but if they don't
the applicants still have within their
power the ability to submit an amended
application ok so we are going to vote
on that all those in favor of deferring
for those reasons please vote now no
three chairs
well those against deferring for okay so
we're not going to defer we've had a lot
of debate capsule Charles I'd like to
propose refusal but I wondered if there
could be a note along with the refusal
that in the event there is a further
application that the earliest
opportunity consideration is given to a
full meeting taking place between
conservation officer ward member Parish
Council and applicant to interview to
trying to a greer proposal pre
application or being fully assessed yeah
I'd second that and those sentiments and
I think we've seen we've now got the
potentially for the first time parish
council backing for this obviously
everybody wants this to happen and I
think this council should go out of its
way more than usually it would and I
know it does a very good job normally
but even more so in this instance so
that's a proposal in a second - any
other comments or should we go to the
vote go to the vote so this is two
separate one so this is for the planning
application 1802 two to nine for to
follow the three reasons for refusal or
those in favor of
with fusing application for jamming all
those against that all those abstaining
okay so this committee has refused to
has resolved to refuse application 1802
294 will now go to sorry about that
will now go to the listed building
consent it was a further application
counselor baths 1802 to 300 lb see all
those in favor of refusing that
application vote now for channel or
there's gainst abstaining three channel
so we have resolved to refuse that
application as well thank you very much
and we'll go into the next next item
which is Barton Road welfare not Aven
and again Charlotte Dix
okay we're gonna have a not a two-minute
refreshment or because if refreshment
break
okay here we go thank you very much
Thank You chairman the site is indicated
on the map by the black circle the
application site is located on the
southern edge of the local service
village of Welford on Aven this slide
shows the application site edged in red
the site is open vegetated land which
was set aside as lek logical enhancement
areas part of a previous approval on the
site the nearest public right-of-way is
indicated by the dotted green line to
the east of the site there are dwellings
abutting the site to the north east and
west with a garden to the south this is
an application for full planning
permission for the erection of three
dwellings this slide shows the proposed
site plan three dwellings wood fronts
onto the new access driveway which had
run to the north and provide access onto
the Barton Road this slide shows the
proposed street scene as viewed from the
north along the new access driveway the
pitched roof dwellings would measure
approximately six point eight meters in
height plots one and two would feature
attached garages whilst plot three would
have a single garage to the north this
photo is taken from the north of the
application site from the Barton Road
showing the housing developments on dams
enclose the entrance to the site is
visible on the left-hand side at the
rear of the photo where the Clay's
boarded fencing can be seen this photo
is taken further into dams enclosed
facing the application site numbers six
seven and eight dams enclose are visible
on the right hand side of the photo but
the sites are positioned behind their
clays watered fencing this photo is
taken from within the site facing south
towards the garden of broad highway and
the open countryside beyond this photo
is taken from within the site facing
west the side elevation of number one
Holland Maday is visible on the
right-hand side of the photo just to
clarify there are updates within the
update sheet
Officer recommendation is to grant full
planning permission subject to the
agreement of assigned section 106 to
secure the biodiversity offsetting
contribution and the conditions and
nights on pages 32 32 of the agenda
Thank You chairman thank you very much
and we are going to hear from Kansas
Simon Carter from Welford on Aven Parish
Council objective good evening you know
the ropes
good evening councillors the Parish
Council have taken formal planning
advice in respect of the above
application which concluded that the
applicant is actually formally in breach
of their section 106 obligations
relating to the ecological and landscape
area the 2013 application was supported
by the by the Parish Council for 12
hours is 8 affordable and for market the
area in question is identified for it
was identified for its ecological
benefit and the condition was included
in the Senate section 106 deed although
it was damaged as part of the
construction of the eight affordable
houses the applicant could legitimately
have attempted to make good that
situation post construction and comply
with a section 106 obligations but
nothing was done this seriously brings
into question the effectiveness of the
section 106 process and the accompanying
conditions
this one's been clearly just ignored if
you can just ignore section 106
conditions then you know you seriously
have to think about so what's the point
of agreeing them clearly the right route
forward today is that the current
application is refused and the original
application is referred to enforcement
that's actually what should technically
happen now the parish council do oppose
the loss of ecological space and
biodiversity within the confines of the
built up area it's getting tighter in
welford as you well know remembering
that the MPP F of course looks for
biodiversity gain in all developments
and we would contest actually offsetting
at this late stage because this wasn't
offered at the start is not a reasonable
compliant approach
the three market houses on the site are
in an area that was identified actually
for affordable homes so actually
affordable market houses aren't really
acceptable there we've more than met our
housing allocation of 84 homes 157 homes
have been consented to in Welford about
a hundred and thirty a complete or under
construction at the moment and we're
currently consulting villages on an
update of our housing needs assessment
survey we've met our 2012 requirements
but we're doing it again to make sure
it's refreshed but we do believe
actually on this site that three more
affordable homes would in fact be quite
acceptable so can somebody please review
this application however as a footnote
if counselors are minded to grant this
application we would either for the
current thirty second option houses all
the the parish council would request
that the ecological offsetting monies of
twenty four thousand are allocated to
Welford on Aven only and i've captured
within the section 106 none of us a
little bit and we've had discussion to
avoid county council on that to make
sure that that condition would be
applicable thank you thank you I've got
a few questions to start with I've just
leave s106 is can after varied for one
reason or another so you can have an
area this is something I'll be asking
the officer so this is why I'm sort of
trying to get your opinion on it you
know you could you could vary that s106
from that plot of land and say right
we'll give twenty five thousand pounds
to just something else or whatever the
sum is and that's that's I think I think
that's a valid thing to do and just like
your comments on that in this
circumstance and we do understand that
it's just that in some ways this has
been a sort of flagrant abuse of the
system so they haven't actually tried to
but if you tried to put in place the
conditions that were applicable this is
actually now going back six years so
it's a long time isn't it to leave it
hence why if you'd sort of said well we
want to do something slightly different
that would be okay the other
point about this location actually is
that all the house is in front of it
exams includes all the affordable houses
the for market houses are to the right
hand side so affordable houses in this
area actually we would like that I think
that would be quite acceptable and we've
had those sorts of discussions of the
parish council so so I go back to that
and I'm not trying to trip you up but
it's just trying get it clear affordable
houses are acceptable on on this site
its market houses we've got enough to
market houses I know these are slightly
smaller market houses but they're bigger
houses and they are actually on the
periphery of the built-up area boundary
so you know there's more impact so we're
looking at you're happy with affordable
houses but you know I'm just thinking
that this is dichotomy between it's okay
to build on it but we want it to be open
to the village okay and just one more
thing on the village boundary right this
is within the village boundaries why is
it in the village boundary you know it
is it is that pre the s106 because it's
you know if this is going to be open
space the original application in 13 the
okay thanks I'll go with council it okay
Perry first
thank you and good evening I note in the
committee report and from third party
responses there are 19 in total of which
18 responses are in support I just
wonder whether you can advise what was
the dish's decision on parish council
was it was it unanimous or was this take
care of Giles does your neighbourhood
plan say anything about this site
specifically refer to it so it doesn't
actually know I mean it's within the
built area boundaries so to a certain
extent you know we've got other
applications we're looking at at the
moment we are very happy to if we get
the right solutions at the right size
and scale you know we support those
applications in many ways our argument
here is actually more about these
flagrant abuse of the section 106 system
actually and this has been six years
just leaving it without complying with
it we've requested on numerous occasions
that enforcement do something about it
we've actually requested that
enforcement do quite a lot of things in
Welford and there are quite a number of
situations were actually not getting any
traction and we do believe it is
important because otherwise you only get
more transgressions that's all that
happens because people are very quick to
pick up on what was said yesterday and
they find that actually they'll ignore
it tomorrow so okay it is an important
thing and I do appreciate your point
that I've actually got no problem at
should be somebody saying well I know
there was a section 106 agreement on
here and actually I want to modify we
haven't got an issue with that this
situation is slightly different in the
sense that they've come forward with
just three market homes without actually
consultation with the British Council
without any discussion and actually you
know when they're pushed that put some
offsetting in
do you have in your neighborhood plan
preferred and allocated site we don't
need those when we still understand
thank you okay now the questions thank
you very much we will now hear from Liz
Nicholson on behalf of the clickin good
evening I'm sure you know how to work
the machine Thank You chair I'm here to
speak on behalf of the applicant and
obviously answer any questions you have
you've obviously got an officer
recommendation of grant subject to a
section 106 to secure about 24,000
pounds towards by the biodiversity
offsetting the officers have concluded
on all of the planning matters raised in
the report that the scheme is acceptable
and that planning permission should be
granted it's not an on balance
recommendation where they've identified
some harm but they feel that this is
outweighed by benefits in this case the
officers have concluded that there's no
harm on any of the relevant planning
matters provided that biodiversity money
is secured going off the council's
figures for last year there's been 123
dwellings built or committed in Welford
during the plan period so far only a
handful of these new dwellings have been
bungalows this is a proposal to provide
three bungalows in a village where the
neighborhood development plan has a
policy that identifies support for Hmong
glows if you just look at this site in
the immediate surroundings there's eight
local choice houses built recently and
they're occupied by young families with
children in the local school adding
three bungalows for older people to
downsize into provides a better mix of
housing in this immediate area
all of the bungles the bungalows have to
be DDA compliant and wheelchair
accessible with regard to the
biodiversity offsetting we've worked
very hard to make sure that there's a
viable scheme where the money can be
spent I did approach the parish council
but unfortunately they didn't want to
discuss the application with me
have liaised with Deric tribe however he
manages the crest Hill ecological site
and with Chris Hill at the county
ecologist and I think he's spoken
directly with the Parish Council it's my
understanding that the sum of money of
twenty four thousand pounds can be
released to the Parish Council to cover
the costs of works and maintenance
identified in their five-year rolling
plan for the kress hill site finally I
ask you to consider that apart from the
Parish Council objection as you've
already discussed there's only one
letter objection and there have been 18
letters of support and there's also the
support of the ward member obviously
just quickly I think I've got enough
time to pick up on a few points from the
parish council there is no policy
requirement or legal duty to provide
affordable housing on this site
conversely there's no policy reason to
refuse the principle of market housing
on this site it's within the built up
area boundary of Welford offsetting as a
process is compliant with call strategy
policy cs6 and that value of twenty four
thousand six hundred and ninety four
pounds is based on the ecological value
of the site if the site wasn't
identified as an ecological area that
value would have been about ten thousand
pounds so there's been an uplift in the
sum that's being paid because of the
ecological value recognized for that
site thank you okay thank you any
questions council fueling person to
answer this one but there is a thing
about location of bins and then we have
a 11 sorry I have 1100 litre euro bin
for general waste and then later on we
have really been to standard
requirements for all new dwellings
well the bins will just be provided in
in compliance with the conditions so the
condition is a standard one for three
bins per dwelling and that's where are
you we're aware of you suggested putting
them with regards to what refuge
laureates coming up beside there's
sufficient room in the gardens people
can bring them to the front and
the street scene officer hasn't said
that the lorry cannot reach but you'd be
better asking the officers I think if
you want more details I think that's
right thank you very much Cantor Giles
what would you say about the parish
council saying that the section 106
wasn't implemented and the reason for it
I can't answer the question to be honest
I've only been brought in for this
application so I wasn't involved at that
stage the only thing I can say as I say
is that the site has been assessed on as
though that ecological value had been
put in so even if it hasn't been put in
the increase in money is more than twice
what it would have been okay thank you
thank you oh sorry councilman thank you
just to carry on with the refuse
situation the plan I think shows a store
area for the large bin that sits at the
top right hand corner there so is that
no longer going to be there I presume
not but to be honest I've been so busy
thinking about biodiversity that all I
know is the conditions are on there to
provide three standard bins and as far
as I'm aware that's what will happen and
that will satisfy the the street scene
officer and there's no no problem with
doing that but again the officers can
probably tell you more about what street
scene they're asking for casually Giles
I just wondered if we could have the
drawing of the front of the elevations
yeah I just wondered what material was
proposed for the garage doors because it
just looks a little inactive to me they
look like metal up and over don't they
but if you were troubled condition could
could change that yeah I mean oh yeah so
you think that might be better we don't
not sure okay okay thank you
come on thank you really
the word detached garages to the house
he looks like there's a gap between the
two that's all what was that Clara told
by the planning officer that they were
attached garages or understand this
herder is that one isn't to others
anyway thank you very much
lovely and we were not going to cancel
the baths
so I thought I'd lost my voice earlier
but I think it's alright
this is a bit of a complicated one
really I think it's originally we had
eight affordable homes and four homes
for locals if you understand poor local
people obviously the affordable homes
went first the grass the Oldmeadow that
was there which did used to flood was a
some sort of ecological value was done a
study on it and they did find one or two
things during all the building of course
the field sort of got to go and end up
with no grass so in theory we hadn't got
but we did have an ecological patch so
the arrangement was that we would sort
of be somewhere else
in the respect of the bungalows I said
to them you know there is a shortage of
bungalows in the village if you are
going to build it something because we
officially should have been one there
but not three so situation then became
that's why they're wheelchair friendly
the bus stops across the road and turns
round so that people can actually go -
we did try and get the bus down to the
caliban side two hundred yards down the
road and couldn't get it but it does
help opposite so they are in an
accessible place and then there was
concern over this money which was pretty
nearly 25,000 and we obviously didn't
wanted going you know on a pond or
something Indonesian but as the chairman
and the Parish Council said we spoke to
the County Council we've spoken to the
office area we have an agreement that
the parish or the District Council will
hold the money so they can be used on
certain environmental things at the
school or in the parish
agreed by the parish council so it's
been a long battle we have got the
affordable homes we've got the green
which we haven't got but we got
bungalows instead and we got the money
on charges simply by a long bus we'll
really but that's where we are and say
with the legal agreement that we now
have or have a your solicitor will go
through it if you want so we feel happy
that that's the way forward okay lovely
no questions thank you very much the
fielding I do know anything about bins
if you do a study on something he don't
know what you're gonna say
the snakes everywhere if you want to put
it that way and I think that's quite
about it you know thank you very much
kind of fitting for your additional
addition to this thank you very much
councillor okay yeah great okay so
questions to the offices organ yes I'm
still exercised by the lack of clarity
about the bins the devil is always in
the detail and I'd like to see some
detail
I'd like confirmation that the bins
store will not be where it is shown
position their confirmation that the
condition 10 which says three bins for
each dwelling is correct which I'm sure
it is and that those three bins will be
kept on the individual properties not in
a bin store area opposite the existing
terrace of dwellings and also I presume
looking at that that the refuse Norwich
lorries and recycle Norah's will not be
able to get up there so that there is an
agreed collection plan put in place for
this
the way Sturmer cycling officer was
consulted as part of the application
based on the originally submissive plans
which did show up in collection area in
this location up here the only issue
that had raised with the with the
proposal was the size of the bins rather
than the carrying distance or the
collection point however we have put a
condition turn on as a standard
condition as you mentioned which would
require the three bins for each of the
three dwellings
if each members see fits who adds a
certain requirements to that condition
that's certainly something that we could
look at in terms of collection points
okay yeah I still just need a little bit
of clarity about the bins door that's
shown on there is it proposed that the
nine bins go in that bin store or is
that bin store no longer going to be
there yeah I think that the conditions
provided by officers don't specifically
say what would happen in that respect
and it remains an element of the plan
that there should be a store there but
we've imposed suggested that we impose a
condition for three bins to try and
satisfy the waste recycling officers
comments I think an appropriate solution
in this case because there is the thin
end of a thread here that needs tying
off would be a condition that required
the applicant to submit a bid management
strategy as you described it that greets
the final position of bins during the
week and during collection and that
would be subject to the agreement with
officers when they submit the details of
that plan that seems quite reasonable
councillor Giles I just wonder if he
could help with the matter raised by the
parish council about the law what he
would say is the lack of enforcement
over the section 106 and I suppose the
relevance it has up
I know what the answer to the last part
is but I would like to know a little bit
about my first question it's difficult
for me to speak to that I don't work in
the enforcement team so I can't judge
the rest to comments around previous
complaints about the use of this land
and whether or not the section 106 has
been appropriately enforced in terms of
the handling of this application we have
to judge the proposal on its merits in
accordance with the development plan
policy it is certainly within the
applicants gift to seek to vary the
section 106 and our assessment is
undertaken on the basis of the core
strategy and the Neighborhood
Development problem and we can't find
conflict at this stage hence the
recommendation of approval as a
committee are we bound to say as long as
there's a satisfactory financial sum to
swap the you know ecological benefit we
are obliged to say that that is a
sufficient offset or was it still a
matter of planning balance so if for
some reason we felt this particular
piece of land in within the built-up
area boundary was important in this
particular location that could it was
theoretically outweigh that financial
officer thing I think in a hypothetical
scenario you could identify a piece of
land that was particularly important for
biodiversity or particularly important
to the setting of a village and
therefore would be appropriate to retain
it and even though the core strategy
does set out quite clearly that
biodiversity offsetting is an approach
which to this Authority does support and
is an approach which we have implemented
and undertaken on a wide range of small
and very large sites so I think you
would have to have particular grounds
officers haven't seen those grounds on
this site at the moment it's not
offering ecological benefit
I was a bit confused in the update it
says officers recommend decision on
which local site to spend the vote
biodiversity offsetting when it should
be delegated to officers is that in
conflict with what's been suggested that
there is some idea about where this
money would be allocated I mean to make
it clear I think money absolutely should
be allocated for welfare benefit but I
just want to make sure that that
condition is tight enough because one
where he is say there is a delay and
build-out and it's a different office so
and they're not really aware of our
comments tonight with approach council
they still monsters and watcher that can
go somewhere else things have moved
quite quickly in respect of the section
106 and the availability of the money
and where it would be preferred to be
spent in respect of the ward members
comments and so on I think there is just
a necessity for officers to satisfy
themselves that the proposed use of that
money is legally sound in respect of
section 106 requirements there's no
objection in principle to what's going
to be trying to be achieved and any
other future officer would be bound by
the resolution of this committee and the
update sheet you know given that there
is still the element of uncertainty
about the potential projects and how
that fits with the requirements of law
in spending that money it's appropriate
I thoroughly agree with the assessment
that it shouldn't necessarily be left to
count sub and to decide where the money
is spent and how but but I do I wonder
whether would it be appropriate to just
slightly amend the wording to say on
which site local to Welford to spend the
biodiversity offsetting so that there's
just a slightly clearest deal okay but
I'm just wondering with that effect is
your hands too great you know it is too
much professor or whether that would be
acceptable
I don't subject to it
albeit that there should be a note
perhaps understood by members that such
fettering of our hands ultimately may
result in the money returning to the
applicant if an appropriate project
couldn't be found or if you know we
didn't agree something was local to
Welford there is an outlying possibility
that that money returns the applicant
after so I guess you could present if at
all possible I think it's fine to
specify local projects in well click in
this intersection one in the resolution
yeah there we go okay on that and what
about the timing of this you know we've
seen six years of the other s106 and
absolutely nothing happens so can we get
this before development or before sale
or whatever certainly but certainly
before occupation certainly it would
normally be something subject to
negotiation between the applicant and
the well I think of this case you
consider in the industry give a clear
steer in terms of whether it be prior to
occupation the money should be received
that's okay we can do that later okay so
we can do it coughs of fielding back
onto the that attached or detached
garages are they actually joined it
seems very narrow between the right-hand
house and the garage there seems to be
quite a large gap but against the next
of the house it seems very tight it
what's the sort of distance between the
garage so plots one and two do you have
attached garage as you can see there is
a single-story flat roof adjoining
section so effectively
so these are the floor plans fair Platz
one and two so the single-story
adjoining section is shown as a utility
for both of those plots okay any more
questions
debate anybody catch the Perry mice will
come further first and foremost whilst I
understand the concerns of the Parish
Council and the comments they've made
personally I can't see any any planning
reason to refuse in their flourish we're
going with the officers recommendation
to support okay
I'm saddened obviously but by this s106
situation and the fact that it's
included in the village boundary with
the view to creating housing which is
more beneficial to the village such as
affordable housing and I do worry that
it's a precedent of some kind that is
being set but I can't see any way out of
that
councillor John I agree with your
comments counts to courage because we
all know the reality is that this
committee and officers approve our
applications on a planning balance and
undoubtedly what would have fed into the
planning balance in the original
application and it being granted is that
we are having secured some open space
that's gonna have some ecological
benefit the idea that we will no doubt
have been sold will it it will look very
beautiful it will be accessible
it will allow wildlife to flourish
within the built up area boundary and it
just all feels very cheap and shabby
that you know actually we then put in a
position well actually no we're not even
gonna it's never even been that it's not
even a question of it was that but we'd
like to do something different with it
as as the parish council have quite
rightly pointed out you have a horrible
taste in your mouth it's really quite a
cynical thing which is will will never
do anything with it we'll leave it
looking shabby and a bit unsightly so
that actually when people look at it
they think who no harm in building on it
so as you say doesn't appear yet again
it appears to be one of those situations
where there is absolutely no planning
ground on which we could possibly refuse
it and it's just all very disappointing
right frankly so yeah absolutely not
going to propose the grant but I'm not
going to vote against this one
Thanksgiving when we granted or when
permission was granted for ten houses in
Thai so it was agreed that the 106
agreement would be ring-fenced
especially for the village for up to
three years I don't know whether this
can be done again
also on scrubland similar to this we
gave permission for ten houses in light
on Heath which had scrubland of the
similar nature last last week I think it
was a lots been said that there's any
merit and me repeating it really yes
it'll disappointing but there's no real
planning reason for us to go again so I
posed that we'd grant in line with
officer recommendation Cara Giles I'm
just slightly anxious because of what
officers said about not wanting to lose
the money in terms of the section 106 on
I'm wondering if we could say in the
wording of that condition a local site
to Welford but in the event that a local
site to l4 cannot be identified officers
have the discretion to identify
alternative appropriate site and then
we've covered all bases we've made it
clear our intention is that this money
must be spent in Welford or local to
Welford preferably with the consultation
of a planning count parish council and
ward member but in the event that it
can't be then an alternative appropriate
site should be found within the district
yes good yes we've heard that are you
happy with a pre preocupación condition
for that mowing as well yeah yeah fine
and we're going to extend the to think
about the bins
for them so that kept all those extra
things in our there was a garage door
thing as well no that's fine I think if
it's you know if it's described
normal-looking Gary's Joe I just
couldn't quite tell from that diagram
what was in position
okay we had a proposal our second that
any more comments so all those in favor
of granting this planning application
with the added conditions and that on
the update sheet no okay there we are
thank you
okay I can add it in so having resolved
to grant planning permission for 1802
four five six four we shall now go on to
Camden Road Clifford chambers and Sara
person then rush
okay thank Jeff the application before
members is an outline application with
all matters reserved for a single
detached three-bedroom dwelling in
Willow cut pastures to describe the
location which is indicated by the black
dots on this plan we can see just like
you can't see just outside the picture
Clifford chambers to the north if you
follow the orange line of Camden Road
there Long Marston is to the southwest
and Welford on Aven to the northwest
here the site can be seen edged in red
these are the only submitted plans the
location plan and the site plan with the
site edged in red as you can see it's on
the edge of the willit will look at
pastures access off Camden Road the site
area is approximately two hundred and
sixty-eight square meters the green box
does indicate the dwelling but this is
indicative only this photo shows the
entrance to we'll look at pastures off
the Camden Road the dwelling would be
roughly behind those trees this is
inside the site showing the approximate
location of the proposed Wehling and
here's that from another angle and this
aerial image of the site shows the
location again with regard to updates
you'll note there's one on the update
sheet and the committee report
erroneously recorded that Welford on
Aven parish council have been consulted
it was in fact Clifford chambers a
Milford Mill Curt parish council that
was consulted and their views are
recorded in the report we have got one
further update and that is that a letter
of support has been received details of
which are on the plan
file chairman the recommendation is to
refuse the application for the reason
set out on page 40 of the committee
agenda thank you thank you very much and
we don't have we go straight to the
applicants Susan Merdan and Sean Starr
okay you don't have to so you have three
minutes and I'll give you a warning at
two and a half minutes and if you press
that button there I think about chair
good evening councillors and officers
the plant site is within our own garden
adjacent to current settlements and is
of an appropriate size for its location
we believed we would ensure any
development would preserve and enhance
the character of the area including
safeguarding the biodiversity within the
site the site would provide in off
street parking were not exactly flooding
nor affect the immunity of neighborhood
neighboring properties if approved we
would work with the planners to ensure a
development and landscaping would
enhance the site and not detect anything
from the surrounding areas furthermore
we believe the proposed site will offer
sustainable development is small-scale
and will be used in land identified as
brownfield going on from our neighbors
extensive plan planned development we
would assume there would be no
additional concerns regarding evaluation
control zone or the gas pipeline finally
before submitting the outline planning
application we spoke to our neighbors to
ensure they would be happy to support
any application and they were happy to
do so and most no objections thank you
thank you very much
councillor Charles if referred to it
being small-scale and I know that the
description is a three-bedroom two
touched Welling is there any reason why
the application wasn't a full
application so we were able to see the
proposed footprint and so forth
unfortunately our agent at a time
advised us this would be the most
appropriate way to go first in
retrospect
wish we had done that but that's where
we are unfortunately okay counselor
fielding two questions one is where
whereabouts is the main house
in that that is in your garden sure if
you you can see just through those trees
there they the main house and then face
in the house if you were the plan
building would be just to the right if
so there would be before the well
occurred pastures was developed as a
holiday area the main house the
farmhouse the track in which you see
where the plan is going to be was the
road onto the main site sense do I
gather from your comments of the holiday
let complexes is no longer in existence
or non you on it no no no we don't own
it at all we only own the main house the
holiday complex is still there and
vibrant and used on a regular basis and
the other comment is that it's noted
that in the ward members response it's
it's implied the dwelling is for the
purpose related to equine care yes we're
small a questionary property we have and
we're planning to grow that as my family
grows where plants become more
competitive so as a consequence we would
need someone on site to support delivery
of our horses we're about we're about is
the Aquinas Center literally behind ways
as will occur pastures just that that is
our paddock in which that we've got 20
by 40 men arch and obviously pasture
land and then just prior to that
building so it's very difficult from
here but there's a if you go to the
write down others wit down outside so I
left apologies there that's our stables
Thank You counselor very good questions
cancer jars I know this is an outline
but I just wondered if he was he's only
outline but I've wonder if he could give
me ideas there any proposed tree loss or
other vegetation loss one would hope not
no that would be totally against our
principles
I would hope we'd have more trees rather
than less to secure particularly from
the main road to support noise reduction
and obviously to reduce any insight
either from the main road
okay so filling another quick have you
done any or have the council asked you
for any costings
to prove the viability of what you're
proposing no my assumption with is
because outline permission we didn't
have to put anything forward again I
would regrettably I wish we put more
information to allow this counselor to
give more an informed choice
what decision sorry okay no more
questions thank you very much okay and
councillor Barnes
thank you I wouldn't have support this
meal really but there is a need if you
look at the map that you put up
whichever might be like I don't mind
that'll do
will it capacitors boss ecology let we
now with the farm opposite have 32
people on the electoral roll so most of
it isn't holiday the big house on the
left hand side is permanent
and in one of the conditions I think
here against it was it was near the gas
pipeline which is two miles away and in
fact I think I might be wrong in saying
this but cancer organ one day as a
meeting on Long Marston thought that the
new village should be called Willy could
because this is a part of an old Roman
settlement which and the village will
come right up to this settlement
settlement as far as I'm concerned
there's a lot people there lot of
activity and you can do the other map if
you like what mom with the road we have
no not that one yeah we have a road
going through the bus service is going
to be reduced from 20 minutes to half an
hour to the Year 2024 with a 106
agreement with the yes and mod will so
on a sustainable site the cattle markets
just across the road with the shops and
vegetables the other thing I think of is
importance is basically is that if you
look at you won't want more in the 30
places I don't think we'll be out of
place
I appreciate it's only outline haven't
got the details and that I suppose is
disturbing but when I got the
application that's what I got from what
I'm della the mother-in-law was to come
down as well because he's just lost
their husband so there are one or two
sort of things
what I was going to say is there is one
reason for refusal on their thing or
would concern ecology when I was
chairman of the council eleven years ago
I went to Caden and the reason the
reason that's there I will explain was
that the go-carts weren't allowed to go
I said to them why's that
they said those newts in the pond they
get killed if they come out on the track
my children used to go there race in
there they'd look for somewhere to put
these newts and not near the river they
wanted somewhere where was sheltered
with houses and trees and they were put
in this bond now that's a perfectly true
story it isn't open countryside these
particular newts like noise like that's
why they went to the weather go-karts
were because that's how they feel you
know some animals like to be quiet some
you know a busy noise so that's why the
ecology people are to a certain extent
opposing the parish council is fully
supportive of it he got to other
buildings across the road which you've
just been approved in a field and I
appreciate what he says about one
planning but a s15 I think applies and I
think that we should be able to move
forward with this one because there is a
need and two it's not too big
and it's seen as far as I can see you
can see a settlement water tables high
that's why it's a Roman settlement or
was a Roman settlement and that's why
the newts lived there I don't think the
people that live there knew of that
story but it's something that's happened
many years ago so I do know the area and
I that's why I'm supporting this and the
parish council normally opposed
everything everything and they're not
the one thing was wrong that the Western
parish was put on the instead of well
put on Ivan
they didn't know where they were but the
point is it's next to the garden village
and as far as I'm concerned one more
house there will be acceptable I think
that's about my five minutes mr.
chairman with my story okay it did it
felt like it felt a lot longer cancer
fielding Conservancy planning east we
gave permission for a suitable
accommodation for a equine situation if
you recall yes yes I remember that how
would you compare this to the one would
you say this is panning East was a
precedent but it's not dissimilar except
that this is in less open countryside
and that was because it's got all these
buildings rounded that's also not in the
report it's not supposed as such we make
a decision on the report it is a
precedent okay no other questions thank
you very much councillor officer
question I'm sorry Charles
if a big if committee were thinking
giving consideration to granting this
but would prefer to see a full
application before they made a decision
in order to properly assess the impact
would it be inappropriate to defer it in
in order to allow that detail to come
forward or would that constitute a
refusal so that then if they want to
make a full application they can you
couldn't defer an outline application
seeking for the applicant turn it into
application unfortunately you'd have to
refuse it they could come back with a
full application okay can organ
can you tell me about those I'm not
aware of the buildings in the field over
the road I can only assume they're bonds
and as far as I'm aware it's a farm over
the road and there that's all I know
thank you
next I don't see any County Council for
highways response on the application
it's an outline application with all
matters reserved and that would include
the access proposals so their views in
respectively this is an all matters
reserved application yeah I asked that
question because it is sort of on that
Ben so I would have thought it might
have been quite important and the third
one Clifford chambers is mentioned in
here as being the parish council it also
says it has a neighborhood plan which is
a consultation stage nevertheless I
don't see anything actually in the
document that refers to that even though
it is only a consultation nevertheless
and I just wondered whether the
neighborhood plan had an identified need
and whether this was an area that was
identified for building lipid chambers
does have a neighborhood plan which is
coming forward it's a regulation
fourteen stage at the moment which has
limited where am i right in saying we
have looked at the policies of that plan
this error is not allocated within the
plan for development and development
within the neighborhood plan should be
based on an identified need
to go forward on this as one of the
conditions an act I would would that be
appropriate that wouldn't be appropriate
the applicant hasn't made an application
for a dwelling which is tied to an
agricultural or equine workers dwelling
the proposal before members is for an
open market loving it wouldn't be
appropriate to tie it where someone has
made such a proposal the condition is
how we would do it these days but in
terms of an amendment such of that that
would go to the heart of what has been
proposed it would alter the description
and so on so it's not something we would
do through an amendment okay debate came
to Perry Thank You chair I think it's
unfortunate that the applicant wasn't
given advice to come forward with the
full application but on that basis it
doesn't conform to paragraph MPP
MPP F 79 we can't look at it from an
agricultural point of view because it's
an outline we can't even look at it in
terms of design but it's also not in a
total isolated area whilst it's open
countryside it then is one can look at
it under a s ten paragraph J but also
from that perspective it's not isolated
because we've got dwellings outside and
because it's an outline application one
can't look at the specifics of the
design and therefore I will have to go
with the offices recommendation for
refusal okay thank you
council Richards thank you Jeff in a
similar vein the officers
recommendations report very clear there
are a number of breaches to cost ratio
in to the MPP F there's nothing to to go
against that offer that gives us
anything to suggest we should be going
against our
policies say I will propose that we
refuse in line with the officers
recommendation okay cancel job sorry but
as you know I'm always quite a stickler
for policy and you know I think it's
really important as a committee that we
are consistent so that people know what
to expect and it's not really about
whether we like or don't like our policy
or you know we ought to stick to it and
so that's probably going to lead me to
agree with officer recommendation having
said that I do find this a difficult
application and I would be interested to
know whether there is any way in which
it could be permitted because I have to
say even though I'm someone who's always
extremely keen to preserve open
countryside here we have an application
which is well shielded from what we're
told the proposal would be not to remove
any trees in fact enhance it by adding
trees it's set against other development
being realistic we know that there's
going to be an extremely large
development within the vicinity and I
think all of those things make it it is
one of those I would say quite
unfortunate cases that it clashes with
policy because I have to say I see quite
limited harm of having a modest
reasonably sized well designed dwelling
here so you know it may be that if there
is a full application when we can be
reassured about the nature of that and
that it's not going to be harmful it may
be there is some way that this could
make a committee could approve it but I
think today I don't think I will be able
to so I would be voting in favor of
councillor Richards proposal against a
fielding and consume any unknowns in
that if it's going to be part of the air
Quine establishment he needs to we need
to have more detail exactly what why
they need it there whether there's an Ag
ty there whether it's going to be B
there too
look after the animals that are going to
be there it does too many unknowns and I
think that I'm going to go along with
the officers okay I'll second a proposal
and we shall to vote all those in favor
of refusing this application unanimous
chair there we go so we have resolved to
refuse application 1803 7 6 8 which I
know one of it is further business
thank you very much councillors
[Applause]